tasty one top is a smart induction
cooktop it helps you cook accurately
because you know at what temperature
things are cooking which will help you
recreate your recipes over and over
again
it also works with special recipes that
we've developed specifically for the one
top as well as old tasty recipes that
use the precision temperatures to help
you get your best results
[Music]
so the one top is an induction cooktop
and all that really means is just that
your pan has to have some sort of
magnetic base to it in some way cast
irons are stainless steel most
non-sticks majority of pans these days
are induction safe so it shouldn't be a
huge deal so a lot of non-sticks now
they'll and just include like a little
magnetic plate on the bottom of them a
really easy way to check if your stuff
is induction if it doesn't say so on it
is to use like a really basic kitchen
magnet so these are some cute little
food magnets aren't they durable and if
it sticks to your pans then you know
that they're induction safe these are
all good to go
[Music]
all right let's talk probes so this is
the temperature probe this is going to
be taking the temperature of whatever
you're cooking so this is the jack
that's going to go into the one top
itself and this is the food thermometer
where the temperature probe is actually
reading is just above the tip
so there's this removable part
you can take off as well this is what
you're going to use if you ever want to
do any sous vide cooking or some of our
deep frying recipes you will put this on
the side of your pan this will hold the
probe in place during cooking really
easy to clean and again because the
whole thing is wrapped in silicone you
really can't melt it all right so again
this is going to go in your food and
this is the end that's going to go into
the one top on the right hand side so go
ahead just like a headphone jack it goes
in really
now in terms of where you're going to
place your probe this is probably the
most important part of when you're
cooking with the probe up here we have
the widest bit it tapers down at the end
so we really want to make sure that
we're getting the food thermometer right
where my finger is i'm going to avoid
any big pockets of fat because that's
going to mess with my temperature and i
want to really get it in the center of
the steak i'm going to put it in through
the side so that the thermometer has
more of the meat to hold on to
so i want that tip to be right in the
center you want to make sure you're not
angling it up or down but you're getting
kind of parallel to the surface of what
you're working so that you're getting a
really accurate reading throughout the
reason why i'm kind of angling it in
here is because i'll get more of the the
metal part in the actual steak which is
going to hold on to it a little bit
better for me and help it stay in during
cooking same deal here with chicken
breast so it's wider at the top and then
it tapers out toward the bottom and
there's a thick part here but i'm also
going to turn it over so even though
this is wide there's a kind of a divot
here and it seems to me that when i'm
feeling it this is the thickest part up
here on the right so that's where i'm
going to stick my probe right there so
i'm going to turn it back over
and again i'm going to angle the probe
from the bottom up just to make sure
that i have enough chicken for the probe
to go in i went here it wouldn't really
be enough here i'm getting much more
chicken to stick the probe into so it's
going to hold on to the probe during
cooking and still have the tip end up in
the most thickest central part of the
chicken breast it's not as difficult as
it sounds promise
then salmon here's another instance just
so you can really like bring the point
home so here we have obviously it's very
it's all the same width right now but if
you turn it on inside you can see that
there's obviously a much thicker part so
again that's where we're going to stick
our probe right in the center there the
only problem is if i came in from the
side there wouldn't be enough fish to
really hold the probe during cooking so
for the salmon i want to come in from
the top down it's going to have much
more fish that the probe can kind of
stick into to make the cooking really
easy again you can kind of feel where it
ends up trying to get in the center
basically i mean it's it's really just
common sense you just need enough meat
to kind of hold on to the thermometer so
that's not falling out during cooking
and also wherever the probe is that's
going to work with our app to give you
the precise result that you're looking
for
all right so you're gonna go into the
one top app this is a dedicated app just
for controlling the one top um full of
cool uh you know perks and tricks and
recipes uh when you open your app it
should automatically connect to the whop
top you'll know when the blue light
comes on on the right that your one top
is connected to the app
we have all these sections in here steak
veggies side sauces that you can go into
or you can just browse all the recipes
that we have specifically designed for
the one top
so you can see all those here we have
tabletop cooking we've got grains all
this awesome stuff and then if you click
over to the compatible side these are
old recipes that we have upgraded they
don't have as much you know precision
control but they still work really
really well and they're super easy and
fun to use in the one top
all right so another feature that we
have is this cute little chef hat up
here and in this section you can connect
to your facebook you can save recipes
and it'll also keep track of all the
recipes that you've cooked so if you're
ever busy cooking you loved it and you
forgot which recipe it was you could
always go back and see those recipes
here and in this white bar section if
you will we have the basic precision and
sous-vide mode so in basic you're just
going to use it like you know a normal
hot plate we're going to go through one
through ten power levels you can set a
timer here which is super convenient uh
we've also got precision mode and this
is where you really wanna set a very
specific surface temperature or
thermometer temperature as well as sous
vide mode so if you find a cool recipe
online you wanna try out on the one top
you don't have to be limited to the
recipes that we've done for you we're
gonna swipe down and let's go into steak
we have all these photos here so if you
don't know exactly what kind of steak
you have from the grocery store you can
choose the one that's closest to the one
that you purchased we're gonna do filet
today and when you go into the filet
section it starts off by saying how many
total steps there are how many
ingredients you kind of know you're
getting yourself into
photos of everything that you need you
can save or share the list you can send
it to yourself when you're at the
grocery store
all the equipment that you're going to
need we have all the steps that you're
gonna be getting yourself into and even
some suggestions for what to eat it with
we just really want you to feel prepared
like you know what's coming again just
gather all of your ingredients make sure
that you're ready to go next is gonna
ask you how you like your steak so we've
already pre-tested all the donenesses
and the internal temperatures are
already programmed in here so whether
you want your steak medium rare or well
done whatever you choose you're going to
get a perfect result we're going to
choose medium rare and let's get going
these decals down here show that we need
a pan as well as the probe to do this
recipe
all right and then it goes through like
a normal tasty recipe
and then when we get to the point where
we're ready to cook in a recipe this
prompt is going to come up saying press
the power button on your one top and
that's just sending the recipe to the
one top so that they can talk to each
other throughout this process so in
order to start cooking you need to have
an induction safe pot on the surface and
then if you are using a thermometer at
any point in the recipe you do need to
make sure it's plugged in before you get
started so one thing that we've ensured
that all recipes have is a preheat step
so you can see it has the temperature
that the is right now as well as the
gold temperature so once the pan is
ready to go at that 380 degrees then
it's gonna proceed and you're gonna be
ready to go to the next step
and so once we're ready to go we're
gonna put our steak into the pan making
sure that we're getting a good amount of
oil on it as well as good contact with
the pan as always and then we're going
to press start so we have a timer built
in to get a good sear on both sides
according to the doneness that you want
again always ensuring we're getting a
really good crust by pressing it down
these cascading lights just mean it's in
recipe mode so that's when you know the
app is telling the one top what to do
and then when the timer is up we are
ready for the next step
later on in the recipe the timer will
turn into a gold temperature so as soon
as our internal temperature of the steak
is 125 degrees it's gonna alert us and
we know now to take our steak out it's
done cooking but this will also work
with old tasty recipes and this one my
favorite old tasty recipe is the
honeycomb toffee and it'll work with the
one top as well it's a little bit
different because we did these recipes
prior to developing the one top but
it'll help you with the temperature
control and all of that and with this
recipe especially helps me get to the
300 degrees fahrenheit that i need in
order to make the honeycomb so even if
you're not following a tasty recipe you
can still use the one top and you can
control in the app itself or manually on
the unit but the cool thing about this
is even if you are in basic mode you're
still getting the temperature of the
surface as well as whatever the probe is
reading so it's a much more accurate way
to cook because you know exactly what
temperature you're cooking another thing
that's really great about the one top is
how low the temperature can go so i'm
not that afraid to melt chocolate on
this thing because i know this can go
lower than any of my other stovetops can
or any other hot plates gives me a
beautiful result and i don't have to do
a double boiler or microwave it or
anything i can do it all right on the
one top so it's even good for these more
delicate tasks as well
[Music]
one thing i hate about cooking is
cleaning my stove and the nice thing
about the one top is that it's so easy
to clean you just spray any really like
soft easy household cleaner vinegar
works really well as i'm just like soft
dish soap diluted with a bit of water
would work fine but you know you don't
have to lift any grates you're not
getting under that weird kind of crevice
in between your stove and your
countertop or anything that always
catches food it's disgusting and then if
you have any really bad stains on it or
anything any good glass or cooktop
cleaner will work really well on the
surface itself
tasty one top combines duction cooking
with precision temperature control
making it easy to cook all of your
favorite recipes with one appliance when
following a recipe in the tasty app the
one top automatically adjusts its
temperature to precisely match the
recipe instructions the one top
thermometer probe measures the heat of
your liquids meats and fish to cook to
the desired temperature or your chosen
doneness
use the one top for almost any type of
cooking sous-vide pan fry stir-fry grill
simmer saute slow cook sear and poach to
perfection
[Music]
welcome to the tasty one top it's the
best